[Music]
three two one action
hey guys on the night off the record we
talked about when we got Tim for the
millionth time so sick of me and we have
the band over here the official song of
off the record available soon on iTunes
for a very high price but maybe you
shouldn't talk this episode it should
just be notes that you hit for your
reaction that's me a question
hey Joe are you happy or sad right now
that's that sounds sad that's some parts
of the Caribbean shake me - oh thank you
thinner mafia yeah he's gonna make us
offer we go
how's your relationship life how did you
love life before how's it before
[Music]
do you see a future with this lady wow
that's uh I hope she's not watching are
you hungry
what Joe do you miss your dogs near the
[ __ ] train from mr. do you think your
dad's a library
[Laughter]
No
no that was amazing that's really cool
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's not a very it has one way of
expression yeah happy it's just that
it's just that question Matt [ __ ] it
kills me every time yep it one more time
hey is your dad dead or alive man you
can't really express anything else but
happiness oh my dad's at the age were
like if he doesn't come to my house for
like two weeks are you worried - really
yeah he's not like all old but he is
like I think he just broke 70 so like he
comes every every Thursday during jake
kinney's and he plays the tiger for a
couple hours and there's a nice Ole Miss
he doesn't really care about us yeah
he's mother for tiger
do you praise I'll have a text to the
text my mom does my dad doesn't do they
use line I don't know what my guys oh oh
line is like I mean I guess it's a
really pretty popular in Asia thing it's
like whatsapp or like yeah so my parents
use line so much like they don't really
have like an understanding that line is
different than Facebook messaging or
texting or whatever they'll be like oh
yeah um did you line with Rick about
blah blah blah I'm like mom Rick doesn't
have line oh that's them saying like
text yeah so they were like oh you know
did you know line it to me send me it on
line we're like oh did you line your
cousin like no one uses line except for
me and you guys do that in Asia though
huh did you got an age aware they call
it lining I guess your dad gets in a car
accident it's you like I'll just lie me
just let me in info line 9-1-1
that's strong Brandon that's like can
you
Kleenex me yeah it's Kirkland but it's
Kleenex call it Kleenex tissue just like
q-tips are actually q-tips is the yeah
oh but he says it though yeah the brand
just owns it like coke coke and then
they give you Pepsi are you guys Pepsi
people are cooking I'm a coke people I
used to be Pepsi and I got converted
same I used to be a Pepsi person until
uh well because also I was working when
I was working helping Pizza Kitchen all
we had was like they were a Pepsi owned
have you tried Pepsi recently it tastes
like [ __ ] I don't drink soda anymore so
that's what I think it changed it's bad
I don't want to talk to you too much
[ __ ] about it because I hope to get any
Pepsi brand same here same here yeah
yeah yeah no I love it I'm hoping that
those parts of me for my authenticity
yes yeah I didn't even drink that much
soda until I try to I got into fitness
ironic huh wait why why do you before I
was unhealthy healthy guy and then yeah
when I got into fitness ironically it
was like how do you fill up these things
called carbohydrates and it I was like
sodas one of the best ways to fill that
number up also you were reaching your
carb intake from soda it's probably not
the healthiest thing I didn't waste
whole grains the ball yeah oh man but it
was difficult interesting I I will only
ever drink soda or I'm drinking alcohol
you know and I get a little Jack and
Coke or I talk about Mountain Dew Baja
blast is its Pepsi please - ah how do
you not drink soda though when you eat
like fast food and other things like
pizza I I have to combine it with a soda
like a Pepsi or something or a coke @np
bubbles I just have like I have lemonade
i canti McDonald's without a coach yeah
their [ __ ] is all about that advertising
[ __ ] in my head
because I'm eating McDonald's I go I'm
gonna have water what yeah by the way my
cup of coke has to be like wet on the
outside Percy beated yes or or or oh I
have like an iced tea
unsweetened wow you're so disciplined
you're a masochist why would you do such
a thing
I just to make myself feel better about
myself you're not that crazy I drink
water with practically everything
no you're healthy yeah I just feel weird
eating or drinking soda now like last
night
it was really really late and everything
was closed so he's he got some
McDonald's oh we're working here and he
got me a coke and I was like oh yeah I
forgot about this with it but wasn't
that [ __ ] delicious yeah I only drink
like this much of it and it the big-ass
cough so such a big ol waster so yeah
people always save me the meme where
it's like oh no no I don't drink so it's
bad for me and it's like the guy downing
Hennessy so true my ass about water and
they drink all kind of [ __ ] right well I
put this poison in my body you know
what's amazing though is that okay see
so Tiger let's talk about Tiger corner
second quantum tiger Quan has somehow
baby as a baby he doesn't like in and
out correct not really he likes
McDonald's so why the [ __ ] how the [ __ ]
did that happen how are they that good
at advertising and branding that they
already reached him as a baby to like a
trashy ER burger yeah so to give you
guys some context this is what's crazy
about so we know he loves McDonald's
right every time we drive by he sees the
golden arches it goes crazy and when I'm
on a diet it's easier for me to go in
and out and custom order some crazy like
like for patty and lettuce protein yeah
and then something like wow just get him
a meal too so I try to get it as close
to I started off with what I thought
would be tasty for him which would be
like an animal style hamburgers extra
sauce in there and just cheese growth
onions but I'm like after a couple times
of him eating it I'm like this is way
too adult friend isn't care about this
and he doesn't go crazy over it the
weight does McDonald's which is just
simple ketchup mustard pickles so I knew
sprinkle of that onion so I get that I
give him that exact thing ketchup
mustard no spread and I give it to him
and he'll go like this he just drops it
and I'm like what the [ __ ] he knows
different friends well are you you know
this let's check this out do you get
Happy Meals friend when you go to
McDonald's yeah yeah we do check it out
so I did a roll
Novak college and the report was like
the the it was a class about like
seduction and human sexuality was warm
yeah yeah was not what's it happy with
the class was human sexuality no wonder
I get horny at the McDonald I I did a
report on like how businesses like
seduce you without you knowing it right
and you know as a little kid you go to
McDonald's cuz you want the happy meal
and then when you exactly and when you
get older you associate being happy and
getting this toy with this chamber
you don't Sam because it's reducing my
child yeah oh yeah big-time
there's no [ __ ] till you give them
much when abling them didn't feel
complete as a kid when you got the happy
meal and there was no toy in there I was
like what the [ __ ] then adult I
[ __ ] my toy so then it's like
you want the toy and in your in your
head in your subconscious right you're
like this cheeseburger makes me feel
like I'm getting a toy Tim there's a
loophole for in this ok so in the early
90s if you guys remember Tim Burton's
Batman Returns came out yeah and they
had a huge McDonald's toy book yes
and I remember sick is Batman but it was
a sick it was sick it was metal but it
was that movie was [ __ ] scary as [ __ ]
and so all these kids are going to
McDonald's and they're getting reminded
about how [ __ ] scary them uh uh and
then parents are getting pissed and
dolls while [ __ ] you selling toys yo
movie where the penguin bites a guy's
nose the penguin was scary man that was
a great movie by the way to date one of
my favorite
Burton movies or movies ever it's crazy
because you say that and the only thing
I remember from that movie is that scene
with the penguin bites and those off
right a little kid yeah the entry where
it's like mo baby Moses that's in the
canal and then they find the [ __ ]
baby and it's so disgusting that yeah
now in the sewers no the baby they give
birth to the penguin he's so [ __ ]
disgusting that they decided to give
them like throw them in a [ __ ] River
I literally don't remember anything
except that no sense remember the
beginning of the movie right we're we're
Bruce Wayne sitting on
Bruce Wayne sitting in a [ __ ] chair I
don't even know what he's waiting for
Bruce Wayne just chill learn the [ __ ]
chair and then all of a sudden the bat
signal goes off and then these gigantic
[ __ ] lights on the side of Wayne
Manor
with bat singles on them turn and shine
the light into his window and the bat
signal is all over his [ __ ] wall and
he has no neighbors who are like I think
he's Batman like it's wild dude we watch
that [ __ ] it's crazy
well speaking of McDonald's in
advertising that's true time for our
sponsor post meets when you need red
wine at 4 p.m. sushi at 9 p.m. a
breakfast burrito at 8 a.m. or ibuprofen
at 10 a.m. you change your job you have
a headache you can post mate it post
mates is your personal food delivery
grocery delivery whatever kind of
delivery you need all year round
anything you're craving post mates can
deliver they're the largest on-demand
network in the US and offer delivery
from all the restaurants grocery and
convenience stores traditional retailers
you could possibly want or need 24 hours
a day 365 days a year
post mates will bring you what you need
within the hour Wow no more trips to the
store you don't even have know where the
store is post mates will deliver
anything to you so download the app for
iOS or Android for free browse local
restaurants and businesses and track
your delivery and real time for a
limited time post mates is giving our
listeners which means you guys $100 a
free delivery credit for your first 7
days to start your free deliveries
download the app and use code off the
record that's cold
off the record for $100 of free delivery
credit for your first 7 days will you
download the pulse Bates app anything
perfectly put any time you need it
postmates it
download pause me to save the call chop
the record I believe they're giving away
100 bucks like that that's pretty that's
a lot that's really good um so I
remember being a little kid and always
getting at me alright and then feeling
like I'm too old for having nails really
I don't remember how old I was but I
remember looking at the value meals and
being like I'm gonna get the number two
because I'm growing now
which was two cheeseburgers instead of
like that is bombs they happen you know
just one cheeseburger I'm like I'm too
grown for that two cheeseburgers and
feeling like almost like a man now yeah
like you're a big boy now remember
eating a Big Mac for the first time yeah
that's what crawl in the beginning
because I only ate Happy Meals my family
was more of a talk about family no
offense to you guys
were more Mexican I guess so and so so I
remember the first time that I got to
order a number because I was buying it
for myself was a huge deal cuz my mom
used to just like give us the 89 cent
tacos and burritos but Corian number was
like holy [ __ ] and ordering a Mexican
pizza for myself was like dude I use
ordinary skin pieces - I still do you do
yeah my go-to is the two beef chalupa
Zara steak so number six
okay with a Mexican pizza you don't get
the Doritos tacos that's my [ __ ] now I
don't really like home I just get the
ranch Dorito taco supreme that's it
that's all I get now there's a sleeper
hit then no one knows about the shredded
chicken burrito I'm telling you it's
like it's it's no one really goes for it
but that [ __ ] is crazy
have you guys had the the cheesy gordita
constantly it's pretty good [ __ ] [ __ ]
you up dude that's a good one oh yeah
it's crunchy that's the taste of my
people it's like a punch you quesadilla
right that thing yeah man I defend Taco
Bell so much there's like a bell
bro so maybe people talk [ __ ] about
tacos now I'm not talking [ __ ] I'm just
saying del Taco is way better you're out
of your mind you just roll along this
way by both I like both but whenever I
treat about whenever I say yo I like
talk about people like oh good luck
later when you're on the toilet I'm like
it's [ __ ] meat and cheese and
vegetables I never get tired makes you
[ __ ] not me you know what I think I
think people are over ordering talkable
if you don't order too much food to talk
about you're not gonna find have the
crazy do be angry I talked about
cleaning your system I don't get it this
is detox also I think if talk about
makes you [ __ ] like that and you guys
just like a bitch-ass weak ass
stomach
rousing their [ __ ] in hot sauce
well Diablo is [ __ ] good fire really
fire though I mean it's not really spicy
what about the mild though is the mouths
where it's at yawns like nobody thinks
that literally nobody no bro sorry loves
I mean no Rick Rick likes the miles
that's why zebu I don't hate this but
he's never on my team we're on the
talked about team in this case all the
hot sauces are the same level of spicy
you guys should cross over to Del Taco
because they have different crinkle
fries don't scorch Oh is for [ __ ]
only well it's not about the spice it's
about the taste the mild what is like
the xxx one is not even that sex at all
what'd you say I said I'm too full to
talk about
did we not talking to you we're not
talking to you then hey we're talking
about you talking about tacos are you
I could eat and talk about food after I
just how much talk about we just sold
right now we got a sponsor from
McDonald's you guys need to go out and
tell us Pachelbel to sponsor us yeah
send an email jeez stop I don't want to
go no hey Tim can you can we tell talk
about that I'll drive a [ __ ] talk
about mobile crawling here [ __ ]
burrito supreme if you guys want so
every video to talk about and send it to
Del Taco to show them that I'm fighting
for del Taco we've hooked up you guys
say that [ __ ] and we get a sponsorship
from Dell talking yeah right right
what if we get one from Taco Bell then
you have to sit here
I hope we get Taco Bell first all I'm
saying is we are a representative here
of different nations of true true and
can I take people that say like talk
about is not real Mexican food like
uh-uh like we're not going to talk about
to get Mexican food we want to talk
about a good Taco Bell has del Taco
that's like people saying that they go
to Chili's to get real food taco means
what is Del Taco me of tacos of the Taco
Bell you turncoat stomach ass [ __ ] no
he said something like that son I don't
think you trying to sell them I don't
know it's not contested you got a weak
and tested yeah yeah so like every year
Taco Bell they do this friendsgiving
where they invite I like like a handful
of people to come do like a Thanksgiving
dinner but they they repurpose Taco Bell
food and they make it like sushi and
I'll send an email
forget connected to all these things
well he has a lot of followers no no no
no you guys have a lot of fun tomorrow
you know those moments way better than
mine
but not important it's because I look
that up what no no because I look at
your likes compared to follower ratio oh
I thought I'd talk about a wedding veil
no silly no you're silly more gay I
defended talk about so much that someone
slid on my DMS and they're like hey
would you like to come to this event
because I'm always [ __ ] riding hard
for them on Twitter yeah cuz people are
stupid they are student used to like
them something changed when they changed
their logo why is this the only big
company you won't stick up for I know
what do you know no there's something
about del Taco that I just ride hard
with you know but they sell driver dog
that's confusing it's chili fries at
least they know where they belong
Mexican food Mexican food in American
food I will say that the don't taco
nachos they give you a way bigger
portion yeah with the holotype okay
[ __ ] you on the Porsche they don't even
put the hot me give you they give you
cuz they're hoping that you'll be
convinced by the end of your meal that
it was good look I get it
but I like it we talk about is the big
nacho special you can love both yes
really I don't understand that
I just thought talking that they'll talk
yeah the song is real chicken soft tacos
high ideal I do like the cheaper even I
did say that the Doritos were poor so I
guess we could kind of chicken soft at
all yeah we got this mysterious white
sauce that's yeah sorry Joe I don't mean
to go so long guys I didn't mean to be
so hard 2004's I'm sorry come on Dean
I'd go to the Thanksgiving thing you've
Taco Bell by to me you know what I was
so blind about my hatred that I forgot
that their nachos were pretty good
schools I go yeah I'll go eat there over
the weekend talk about natural fries too
which are really good yeah
but they did this buffalo nacho thing
that's whack and they did that should go
away it tastes like vomit nachos really
you know it looks really good I had them
in when I was in Vegas briefly I've
tried a bite of it and I had to spit it
out cuz it's very good did you go to
talk about Cantina write it up they
serve alcohol there I heard you can get
[ __ ] Baja blast like margaritas [ __ ]
you can get Baja marry there - you can't
you get [ __ ] married there's like
eight dollars
you show up you get married as your
marriage - just to get on like a rapper
like a taco
I'm sure get married at the Taco Bell
Lana Stevie pretty classy you can renew
your vows of the talking ball I mean not
you but yeah everyone else you're a
sound that do you have a sound for that
that's not the right size No
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]